welcome everyone thank you so much for
coming I am Heather inertia and the
director of Graduate Studies for the MIT
comparative Media Studies Program
and what we are going to do today I'm
going to give you a brief presentation
and some of it
hello Yvette come on in some of it and
the tone of it is gonna be a bit like
that hello come on in because we have
just just imitating what happened we
have a number of people stopping by who
have you know ten minutes between class
and so we made at certain points
interrupt people to just say a welcome
Ian Connery one of our colleagues only
has a few minutes but we wanted to get
as many faculty as possible and and lab
managers and so on you could come by to
sort of show their faces you can ask
them questions later so there might be a
colloquium later and also they'll be
introducing themselves shannon larkin
over here is our administrative
assistant Graduate Officer dr.
administer academic administrator and
she knows all so she's a good person for
you to follow up with about you know
very specific questions like where do I
put my GRE scores or you know this kind
of stuff and deadlines and that kind of
thing and it's all on our website too
but there's so much on our website that
it can be a lot to navigate so she can
help you with that as well so I'll give
a brief introduction and then we'll we
already have one of our professors do
you think bald you want to sit here it's
a sort of official spot and because one
of our grad students in Mackay is one of
our research scientists so this is our
beautiful building which is just a few
blocks away looking very sort of Wrigley
stopped movie ish there and at CMS we as
you can see address the challenges
brought about my ongoing and fundamental
changes and the technologies and
practices of media production
distribution and consumption and we're
not looking there are a lot of program
out there that are you know TV studies
film studies less than popular music but
things that are kind of siloed by media
and we try to do something that's more
dynamic genuinely comparative historical
and multidisciplinary one thing that is
confusing for some people who come to
the C MSW website is depending on why
they came to the website what CMS or
what's W so in a nutshell comparative
Media Studies merged with writing the
humanists humanistic studies my belief
is in 2012 and there are separate
undergraduate programs where you can be
a major in comparative Media Studies or
major in writing a lot of those folks
you can imagine most people come to MIT
are not coming we have a fabulous
humanities go program going on here but
they come in more often for engineering
or they want to build robots world
domination you know and then they
realize how fabulous our humanities are
that we require eight humanities classes
for the undergrads and they you know
which is more than a lot of
technologically oriented schools and
they end up double majoring in you know
writing and rocket science so we have
these two undergraduate programs and we
also have two graduate programs we have
a comparative Media Studies program and
the graduate program in science writing
which was established in 1999 so we are
part of the School of Humanities Arts in
social sciences if you've been following
the minor if you've been following the
news you might have noticed that we were
recently ranked of one of the three best
universities for arts and humanities
education along with Harvard and
Stanford and then this was by a times
higher education which is a leading
British education magazine and then we
were ranked number one in the social
sciences by that same publication a few
weeks later so that's the propaganda
we're great
we have graduated 90 students or so in
community
studies they work in a range of areas
they're about 30% of them go on to
pursue doctoral degrees
this is Laci Lord another one of my grad
students I will have her introduce
yourself in a few minutes and so about
30 percent of our class and it seems to
happen every year if we take in ten
students about three of them end up
going in pursuing a PhD or some kind of
next step in in terms of degree and
about 70 percent go into various kinds
of professional endeavors game design TV
production management museum education
not-for-profit work advertising
marketing there's a strong Civic
orientation among a lot of students so
some people go kind of more corporate
route so you would go a more
not-for-profit route and are getting
into activism and social justice issues
so it's really a wide range we get about
hundred applications each year and we
admit about eight to ten of that it's
very competitive often we want to admit
15 but we just can't pull it off part of
the reason we can't pull off that large
classes that we really want to fully
fund everyone who comes in by hook or by
crook so some people come in with
outside funding from say the Chinese
government or you know their various
ways that people come from abroad and
may have funding from home but generally
most of the funding we do through
research lab sponsorships that if you
come in you would be assigned to a
research lab working about would you say
20 hours a week that kind of standard
and that pays your monthly stipend which
is how much currently in just over 2,500
a month on a crest question that we all
have on our mind so I'm just going to
tell you right now good to know um and
it covers your tuition which is quite a
lot of money right so you will not come
out in debt from having paid MIT tuition
for two years we find you you you
indicate your interest in a particular
lab when you apply we as we assign you
to a lab but we try to be flexible like
we want to make a good match and we
generally do but we
want to make sure that you we try to
make sure that you're happy in your lab
assignment there's there's a well I'll
tell you about the core in a few minutes
so we'll wait to get to that and to give
a sense of the courses you'll be taking
if you were here and I'll just mention
the addition to the coursework there is
a kind of team emphasis that a lot of
people doing working in groups and
getting engaged in you know doing
speaking engagements publications being
involved in service organizations going
to conferences together this kind of
thing and you know when you're in a
research lab you might end up traveling
somewhere let's say over I ap
independent activities period you might
end up going with your lab to Sri Lanka
to gather data or something like that so
that's really I just made that up
fishery Lanka but yeah you go to
different we do go to interesting places
over you know throughout the urine and
over the breaks and over this summer and
over the summer um a lot of Shannon
remind me over I ap you are you may be
expected to work in your research lab
but over the summer
it varies yes it depends on the
discretion and at this question the
student I'm so many students between the
first and second year will work on
gathering data or reading lots of books
or writing or whatever it takes to gear
up towards their thesis which they'll be
writing in their second year it's a very
intense program and you know even you
know sometimes the first or second day
the new students are like wait I
supposed to know what my thesis is now
but actually we try to bring in students
who we feel like are tough enough to
early on be like yeah I have some really
definite ideas and then you fine-tune
them and hone them and some people shift
directions but we are looking for people
who come in with you know some sense of
their of their purpose why they're here
what they want to pursue maybe
afterwards or at least in terms of their
thesis so I think
that so what what does it mean to be
comparative what do we do across media
we do transmedia work that is
computational media the book used to be
the book games television film and video
we do trans historical work thinking
across historical periods trans cultural
work and transdisciplinary work and I
think the transdisciplinary thing is one
of the things that will will really hit
you the most if you're looking at our
website and you look at let's say you're
looking at other schools to apply to
often within a program you'll say oh
everyone in this program went to an
anthropology has an anthropology PhD
wherever you learn in this program
studied you know as a film Studies major
or you know this kind of thing you you
get a sense of cohesion right where
cohesive but diverse at the same time we
have a lot of different disciplinary
backgrounds in humanities and social and
computational sciences vivec for example
American Studies right as a PhD I was in
a film program in an English department
studying television michaei what was
your informatics part of computer
science yeah so that just gives you a
little taste
you know Audrey he'll be later was an
anthropology so it's kind of all over
the place but we make it work that's
part of what's fun exciting is exposed
to all these different methods
approaches and backgrounds who are we
here's a sample of who we are presented
yeah headshots look how short my hair
used to be so it gives you a sense of
who we've got here and and and some of
these people introduce themselves I
believe Sasha is coming as well but I
mentioned in Condrey our anthropologist
who works on Japan sasha over there a
civic media Federico is a professor of
the practice here was the mobile
experience lab vivek who will describe
his research in just moments fox who
does computational work and runs the ice
lab imagination imagination computation
and expression yeah ice me I'm a
historian of television
broadcast media our work in conservative
media culture Nick Montfort who does
experimental poetry and that's not the
right way to put it um he computational
experimental poetry he literally teaches
machines have to generate poetry for him
and he looked like one of his side
projects now is a book that is entirely
written with three letter words I
believe it's called one for the win I
was in a car trip with him once for four
hours and he was like let's talk about
three letter words very intense about
his words it's fantastic
Jim parody unfortunate couldn't make it
he's teaching right now he works on
additional humanities and surveillance
jing wang' uh is just started an NGO is
an NGO 2.0 correct I remember correctly
so uh will Mauricio does kinds of things
television history film history he's got
a book coming out on algorithms right
now he's the most prolific and why
drinking scholar um one of them that I
can imagine
tl Taylor is a sociologist who focuses
on gaming and competitive published
gaming events eSports Thank You eSports
you can tell now the video game versus
you know that thing with electronic
sports he's won um and it shop as the
head of our program overall of CMS W and
he's in rhetoric and persuasion um does
a range of media work and sort of
classic rhetoric work to give you a
sense of some of the more contemporary
work he's got a piece I believe it's on
Michael Moore sicko where he's looking
at attitudes of people who view the film
and how they are affected by the film
just to give you a specific example so
that's a little bit of who we are um we
as you know have a number of research
labs these are all up on the website
Civic Media Ice hyper Studio which is
for digital humanities mobile experience
and is Federico coming no no okay
game lab open documentary and the
creative communities initiative the
trope take that sneak Mumford's project
and the educational arcade so they do
distinct things but there's also clearly
some overlap education arcade for
example using you know digital tools for
education it's going to overlap in
certain ways with game will have
insurances of antibiotic I think right
that's fair to say
here are the lab directors to give you a
sense of the faces that go with each of
these labs we also have visiting
scholars and postdoctoral fellows some
of them are associated with research
labs but not always sometimes they teach
a course while they're here so we just
have a lot of talented and interesting
people passing through and these are
just three examples if you go to you
could see there's a link there you we
can't really see that you can find it on
the website to all of our post doctoral
and visiting scholars so for example
Theresa Rojas is a comic scholar of who
was a pre doctoral fellow I know it's a
post doctoral fellow it worked she
finished her dissertation and stayed on
and teaches a range of courses force
including comics fabulous Amrita has
made her works on religion and media and
culture she's doing a lot of field work
on Mormon media production she's fun to
talk to about the Book of Mormon and
Sendero Judas is a documentary filmmaker
among other things associated with the
opendoc lab so this is just a little
sample some of the people we have
passing through some of them are here
for more than one year some of them just
for when you're at a time um this uh
reiterates you know this is directly
from the website but just gives you a
sense of what the structure of things
would look like if you were here okay so
in your first semester um it's pretty
it's pretty rigid airtight per semester
right you're in media theories and
methods one to kind of give up since
people come along different backgrounds
helps give you a common language for
thinking about the theories and methods
of Media Studies workshop one is a more
sort of a hands-on team oriented class
with computational work major media
texts is a class that I regularly teach
that
and it's not very revealing major media
attacks what is that gone with the wind
or you know it could be sort of all
kinds of things I'm teaching this this
year around electoral major media checks
of elections and thinking about
political campaigns as text but the idea
is you can take a range of content in
this class as long as you're learning
how to dissect text and look at how
they're put together so that's a tool
that you could use in your thesis even
if your thesis is not text-based and
then colloquium which I'm hoping many of
you will be attending today is every
Thursday from 5:00 to about seven
o'clock and we have a range of speakers
some from out of town some local folks
sometimes within our own department and
today we have an alumni panel so this is
a place to see a range of research get a
sense of different kinds of methods with
when we bring in alums it's useful for
current students to see you know what
are the kinds of things you might do
when you graduated when you're when
you're done and ask some questions do a
little networking perhaps and then we
eat falafel or chicken on sticks shrimp
we had shrimp last week so in a little
modest receptions very nice um the
second semester you continue theories
and methods - that's a class I teach and
it ends with your thesis proposal okay
so with a which could change right
because then you have the summer to work
on it but the idea is you're sort of
lining up putting all your ducks in a
row as they say towards writing your
thesis in so you submit a proposal on a
continuation of workshop from the first
semester and colloquium again and then
you have an elective which hooray
there's a million different things to
choose from at MIT um and also you can
take classes at Harvard at Wellesley at
which few people do because it's a bus
ride but there it's an option mass art
yam s college of art so it's a range but
most people if they leave MIT for that
elective end up going to Harvard and
then in your second year median
transition is a history class
Wow that doesn't sound historical
transition right but it's looking at
transitions from period to period so if
you think about for example the rise of
electrical communication you could start
with the Telegraph in the 19th century
go in the telephone television or you
could back up like Willie Murray Cleo
doesn't work on television you know from
the 19th and 18th century how his
television imagined as the technology
was still slowly developing you didn't
quite exist so it tries to mix up get
away from that kind of teleological
historical approach and looks looks at
moments of transition as new media's
emerge and new media's there's a great
book by Carolyn Marvin called when old
technologies were new all right all new
technologies become old technologies so
that's a classic
yes goes into those issues and then
you've got colloquium again and then two
electives hooray
and then in your last semester you're
taking you're doing colloquium and
writing your thesis some people split
the thesis up into two semesters they
sort of do half that per semester in
half a second and if that's works well
with your work style that's a good idea
um okay so then you write your thesis
and I'm sorry this text is a little
small but these are on a few samples of
theses from a few years ago one it
rather than reading through all these
titles because I do want to move on and
stop talking so much I'll just say that
you can go to our website and see a list
of former theses have been written by
our students and most of them are linked
up that is correct right yeah all of
them there's a few rare examples like
there's one person I know who worked on
industry stuff and it interviewed a lot
of people and they were like you can put
this in your thesis but it's kind of off
the record and she and she and really it
was more it wasn't full of scathing
expose it was just she wanted to go into
the industry and she was like I'm not
sure I want all this stuff you know so
that was available by request but
basically everything is up there so you
can take a look at what's happened
before they're generally 100 page
documents 330 page chapters 5 page intro
conclusion just to give you a general
idea there's some variation and some of
them have a strong creative component
where someone say is doing a big data
visualization project and then they
might write less text and do more coding
but usually it ends up around
pages I'm gonna skip that one um here's
a nice example of one of our star
graduate students who wanted to graduate
school she's still in graduate school
Molly thought her but her book just came
out about civil disobedience on the
internet with a strong focus on
anonymous Molly solder there's a full
list of our alumni online so you can
take a look this is just a nice range of
you know you can see the kinds of things
they do digital director at Adult Swim
autumn and already from 10 a class of 10
Sam Ford from o7 is a VP of innovation
engagement at fusion which is an ABC
Univision joint venture with that
flourish clink doing transmedia
storytelling what's the name of her TV
series he's slow hi Europe yeah yeah um
that's what she's she's one of the big
creative talents on that I've got some
at the NYU Game Center who's an
associate arts professor someone at
Microsoft Research so you can get a full
list online but that gives you a bit of
an idea um I already told you about
colloquium just and speeding up now move
on we have a conference every other year
called median transition this one
unfortunately we had to cancel we were a
little short-staffed we had so many
professors on leave because we all have
these big projects to finish up and so
on but you can read a kind of pricey of
you know the last 8 - median transition
conferences and get an idea some of the
they always have a central organizing
theme and it's a sort of smallish
conference where I believe we don't even
have competing sessions is that right is
it all I think it's just a linear so
it's a really interesting conference and
that's really it there's our life to a
home page of the website so I want to
open it up to Q&A but I also wanted to
hear from our visitors who come in so
maybe we could start with V that okay so
my name is Vivek bald and I've been here
what coming on seven years
since 2008 and my background before I
decided to get I got a PhD later in life
and my background before that was as a
documentary filmmaker but working very
much in the DIY style very small and my
my work both in documentary and now as a
scholar as a historian has centered
around specifically the South Asian
Diaspora and stories of migration and
immigration from India Pakistan and
Bangladesh to the US and Britain so my
documentary films have included a music
documentary about South Asian Youth and
music and anti-racist politics and
Britain another documentary about South
Asian taxi cab drivers in New York City
and my current work is a little bit more
historical about South Asian
undocumented immigrants in the late 19th
20th century who settled in African
American neighborhoods and so that work
is work that I'm now pursuing across
different media so this last project
that I mentioned which is called the
Bengali Harlem lost histories project
exists as a book that was published in
2013 and currently I'm working on a
feature-length documentary about the
same subject as well as an interactive
documentary slash or history site which
I'm making sort of under the auspices of
the open documentary lab it's that
website available and live at the moment
not currently okay wait do we have an
ETA because I want them to look it's
still wonderful I've seen that sort of
thing um I would say sometime in the
spring okay ladies because what Amy he's
got all these I mean you could probably
scribe rather than I can but he's got
these photos up and people go and
they're like that's my grandfather so if
you have unidentified photos and you
invite people who you know say
immigrants to New York a certain time to
look there and you know find their
relative
and tell their stories and add them so
there's a level of genuine interactivity
that I think is really impressive and
interesting there's there's some weaker
interactive interactive documentary out
there where the interaction is just like
click on this and you'll see something
different that if you click over here
it's just you know doesn't strike me as
very interactive and this is a really
genuinely interactive project that grows
and develops through the interaction
it's really sort of committed to the
idea of people's histories and also
histories of undocumented populations
that have existed you know throughout
the 20th century and trying to record
document those story those histories
through family stories and family
photographs you know in a kind of
ongoing way and the open documentary lab
for those of you who are interested in
that is is a relatively recent but very
fast-growing initiative that we have
here that is focused on new forms of
documentary storytelling that have
opened up with various different kinds
of technological changes over the last
decade you know from from kind of the
ubiquity of of cameras on cell phones
and what that does to documenting you
know kind of political and historical
events to game and virtual reality
interfaces as a way of telling what what
might have been an enhanced documentary
nonfiction kind of story and we should
have the director of that research lab
here later Sarah wolves yeah so she can
fill you in more and you can ask some
questions so - so yeah thank you
Thanks before we move on to Anika I just
want to note there's coffee and cookies
over there and you can get up at any
time
don't worry about like it you know
someone's talking just like go ahead and
one of them is only subtly Martita so if
that's what you're going for or not just
take a look at the top of the box to be
certain you're getting what you want um
but anyway
dig in Anika Thanks so I'm a second year
graduate student in CMS
and before I came to the program I I
studied journalism and my undergrad and
worked as a journalist for several years
as a science and technology writer in
the United States and then also in New
Delhi India I also did a lot of work
with collaboration within journalism and
journalism innovation so I started while
I was living in India I started a
grassroots network devoted to
collaboration between journalists and
other forms of technologists and and
then I also did a lot of work with
digital product management within the
media industry and that was doing that
is what I was doing before I applied to
CMS and so one of the things that
brought me here was this joint focus
both on media historically as well as
exposure to the technology driven
culture of MIT and the Media Lab and yes
so that's and then now I'm here and I'm
doing my thesis work around issues of
how user-generated content interacts
with news organizations and using that
as as a way to understand better how
news organizations are reacting to
changes in the composition and relation
the composition of and relationship they
have with their audiences okay thank you
I think before we go to media maybe Laci
Lord is here did you stand up and I'm
sorry I was just sitting up here but she
is also a second year I kind of yeah
stand up and my name is Jason Lord I'm
also a second year masters student my
background I actually came straight here
after undergrad my backgrounds in
English literature and I came in
thinking I wanted to work on transmedia
type experiences and I have worked on
transmedia storytelling projects in the
past my I'm actually a research
assistant with the comparative the
creative communities initiative which is
it takes an anthropological focus so if
you have questions about that please let
me know and my thesis work is dealing
with tablet based digital comics and
particularly looking at considerations
of the senses and how haptic editions
have changed the topic experience and
also how the panel relates to the screen
itself
so that's great thank you could either
of you mention just a few other thesis
project just so they have a kind of idea
of what people are working on sure I can
actually I realize when Lacey was
talking one of the things I didn't
mention is that I'm a research assistant
in the mobile experience lab also known
as the design lab depending on the
project involved but um and I can I'm
happy to answer more questions about
that lab for anyone who's interested and
then in terms of thesis projects we have
a huge variety one of our colleagues
who's working in the Center for civic
media secessionism well is interested in
creating a new platform for live
streaming set up live streaming so he's
building that platform in partnership
with developers there and hoping to
actually launch that and or has started
testing it in many different contexts
called deep stream right dream yeah so
you can go you can go look it up if
you're interested so that's what he's
doing is his thesis work another one of
our good friends and colleagues is
looking at um she she came in with a
background in video games and she's an
avid player as well and so she's looking
at she's actually working with me I'm
looking at feminist narratives within
video games which is really an
interesting space
who else another one Lily another one of
our classmates is she actually did a lot
of work in radio and she used she's
interesting because she kind of has used
CMS as a chance to explore a totally
different discipline and so she has now
started doing a lot of work with urban
planning and she spent the summer doing
a bunch of research in New Zealand
working with an organization there and
she's now doing a thesis related to
urban planning and has people on her
committee from that department okay so
that gives you a nice sample and we're
gonna hear the nikkei thank you so much
okay and then Sasha Costanza stalked
just came in who works in civic media so
we'll do that you too and then I promise
Q&A okay so yes my name is Michael
Jacobson and research scientist at CMS
but I'm also the research coordinators
I'm at a game lab and I think I can
describe both my research and what the
game loved us by how you might interact
with me or us if you become a grad
student here so first of all we have
teaching so we have for instance an
introduction to video game theory class
which is a heavy reading class going
through the in particular the last 10
years of game studies what are the big
themes what are the big topics and
issues and it's it's a great grounding
for a grad student if they want to write
a thesis on anything games related I
also use TAS from the program in that
class and that just makes you have to
read all that literature even harder we
also play games and practice and now
analyzing them and writing criticism on
them in that class I also teach another
advanced class only for grad students on
playful and social interaction designs
so if you are interested in interaction
design and exploring research questions
by building things that that is
somewhere where you can take your
project and it's more of a workshop type
class where we work on them together and
discuss the different topics based on
what are our projects or what we also do
at the lab is research so my current
project is on couch co-op gaming and
I've done sort of a critical feminist
reading of how the second player is
being treated in these games and by
these socio-technical systems basically
what what you find is that there is this
idea of the first player being male
being a skilled gamer and being someone
that almost needs to be have their
experience protected against what player
2 is going to do
to mess it up when they get introduced
into this picture I think it's based on
all negative stereotypes about female
gamers that we need to get rid of and
actually that's a little bit where Kira
called rods thesis project comes in
because as you said she's interested in
looking at what we tentatively called
warm interaction between players or
between player and player characters or
between different player characters and
I think that's a field that we can mine
for coming up with better asymmetric
co-op gaming experiences so well I'm
planning the next step of my project
where I want to work together with
developers on coming up with these new
interaction modes in co-op games she's
looking at what could those be in terms
of interaction modes that aren't just
instrumental like say you have a game
and you need to climb up a ladder if you
add another player suddenly you need to
climb on the other player to get over
the wall but it's kind of the same same
thing you're doing still if we're
introducing different types of
interaction most like caring for other
players rather than just helping them
over a wall if that's part of the goal
of the game then I think we can have
more interesting interactions going so
that's the second way you can be
involved she is a research assistant in
the lab so she's working to with me on
this project in between mine my project
and her thesis project the third thing
that is like the the third pillar of
what we're doing in the game lab is
actually playing games they think it's
really important to not just study
through books or other literature or
think about these things but we think we
actually have to or build these things
we have to also do the activity itself
to really have an inside understanding
of what it's all about so we're doing a
lot of that and we're involving the
students a lot we try to play against at
least once for
what we're doing right now is we've been
playing a lot of board games that have
themes based around imperialism and
colonialism and we're doing a critique
there's going to be a series of blog
posts and maybe a journal article on the
problems we see with how these themes
are dealt with my blog post is
tentatively titled stories of
imperialism and colonialism retold
somewhat lovingly Thank You Sasha would
you mind coming over here because this
is where our microphone is for the live
stream and I guess is the camera right
at the computer right there yes take my
chair okay look like a group photo
Thanks thank you thank you hi
so I'm Sasha Costanza Chuck I'm
associate professor of civic media in
comparative Media Studies and writing
the work that I do and the kinds of
projects that I work on with students
are projects at the intersection of
social movements and media and media
technology practices and the way that we
like to work is typically through
participatory action research and
participatory design so for example we
have one large project that we're
working on which is the transformative
media organizing project and we're
working with LGBTQ and two-spirit
organizations around the United States
to learn about what what kinds of queer
media activism is happening now what
types of tools and technologies our
organizations sort of using and that's
paired with Skillshare series where
community organizers from groups that
are working at different intersections
of race and class and rural urban
location and disability justice and the
prison system and and queer organizing
are
every month sort of doing an online
Skillshare where they'll talk a little
bit about the work that they're doing
and then do some type of hands-on yes
still sharing with other groups that are
participating
you know remotely via Google hangout so
tomorrow actually at noon Eastern if you
go to transformative media CC you can
see a skill share by the two-spirit
journal comm which is a new project
that's launching out of the work that
we're doing to sort of highlight the
histories of various genders that
existed in many Native communities in
the Endit States prior to settler
colonialism and the erasure of those
other genders so we're doing that I I
teach this course that I am really proud
of which is the collaborative design
studio and that course is different
every time we do it but the basic
principle is always that we're
partnering with the community-based
organization or a number of them to
develop some type of media or technology
project together and in the past we've
focused on surveillance and
counter-surveillance technology so we
we've partnered with the Cambridge
domestic violence working group to
develop a project around you know people
who are being surveilled by their
intimate partner who's abusing them and
the different apps and tools that
abusers are using and how do you detect
if those apps have been put on your
phone or are we partnered with detention
Watch Network which is a nationwide
advocacy organization that's looking at
the detention and deprecation system
under the Obama administration which is
deported over you know 2 million people
since Obama came in and they developed a
sort of interactive sort of mini
documentary piece about that system and
what it means and where it came from and
where it might be going in the spring
we're going to be doing the co.design
studio focused on cooperative
worker-owned cooperative so there's this
interesting conversation happening right
now you'll probably see there sort of a
backlash happening around Eber and
Airbnb so there's a conversation about
the on-demand economy and what it means
for workers
and what it means for short a future of
jobs as well as of course what it means
in terms of you know as consumers our
access to these services so the idea is
that you know Silicon Valley is
disrupting a lot of industries in ways
that might be beneficial for consumers
and in some cases might also be
beneficial for workers but they're also
sort of setting themselves up as
intermediaries to capture a lot of value
on the transaction fees from you know
something like uber taking a ride so the
question is can we do disruption that
does more than just replace the crappy
old boss with the crappy new boss that
has even more information about
everybody in the system and so in the
spring we'll be partnering with
worker-owned cooperative to develop new
platforms for the on-demand economy that
would be actually owned by the people
doing the labor in these systems or
their organizations so those are some of
the types of projects and I think it's
all sort of guided by sort of shared
sort of commitments of these ideas these
principles of both research and making
that's done in partnership with existing
community-based organizations and that
ends up sort of owned by the community
that you're working with so rather than
sort of coming in to do sort of
extractive research about a community or
get an idea for your startup that you
kind of like take from a design process
that ends up sort of benefiting you as
an individual most or your company or
the venture capitalists - back to you
our sort of ideas are about like how do
we build things in community with
organizations that that already have
emerged organically from communities
that are most sort of targeted by
structural racism gender inequality
heteronormativity etc so ok yeah thank
you thank you well I believe we have we
we're gonna have some lab manager
starting to come in around three o'clock
that clock is not adjusted for daylight
savings time so we have a good 17
minutes or maybe a little more for just
Q&A open discussion and you can address
your questions generally or to anyone
specifically up here
about what some of the grad students
were saying about people who came in and
that were pursuing the many different
views but what the human - so for me my
ethnographic work is in diaspora but I
also started working at a non-profit
that doesn't worry about this and I'm
interested in doing stuff that helped me
build tech for the second project and
I'm wondering how much how that's
possible to do two projects within the
span of materially or it looks like this
person what's your name
Jill Jill has two different projects and
is one and one of them oh my goodness I
was saying attention but I might even
tell stories um she's wondering about
you know in terms of how her end product
or thesis is she going to be able to do
both of these things will she have to
merge them together and you know
ultimately a thesis has to be focused on
you know one thing so I mean unless your
your topics kind of merged toward each
other in certain ways you're probably
going to end up pursuing one essay a
major project for a class or even for
two classes I mean they're different you
know I encouraged in my own classes you
know okay the classes major in media
text maybe we're not doing textual
analysis but is their topic you can pick
that would segue into a chapter of your
thesis with further revisions and so on
and so there are different ways you can
pursue you know separate interest sets
but you don't want to be overly
ambitious with a thesis that is too
ungainly and it's more like a PhD
dissertation than a master's thesis sure
I add to that I was gonna mention that
both of the things that you specifically
mentioned but also I'm sure this is true
for other people who have multiple
interests both of those like both the
tradition of like ethnography as a basis
for analysis and drawing conclusions as
well as building tools for civic
intervention
participation are things that have like
a strong tradition within CMS as well as
a really rich and vibrant community in
the broader Cambridge area
so you know that people have also kind
of addressed that by potentially
participating in like working groups or
finding other partners to work on
projects for example like this the
second space that you mentioned is I
think you could find people who would be
really interested and have a lot of
experience and be willing to talk about
that with you even outside the thesis
environment and I think people do do
that young as well
Thanks that's helpful yeah and it points
to I mean there's a lot of resources in
Cambridge Massachusetts like them yeah
or you know in the area in Boston - it's
like a kind of brain trust a lot of ways
so you can always you can reach out and
find things outside of just this little
tiny area yeah it's hard not to find
them actually there's so many yeah
exactly that's more questions yeah yeah
good question sorry you're here you go
hi am i I wasn't know for the students
in this program I know you said that you
came to undergrad I - I'm a senior now
an undergrad so I was just below asking
if you have any tips for people who
don't have these years of professional
experience who are coming through
undergrad how to strengthen your
applications and what focus on when you
are applying I'll just repeat if you
come straight from undergrad how do you
strengthen your application since a lot
of people applying have more experience
etc so general tips I will say I thought
it would be more I thought there would
be more of a difference between me and
other students who had had more years of
experience and really what it boils down
to is that there really is not a whole
lot of difference in how the program
works for you I will say general tips
and as far as like focusing like when
you're applying I took the route of
focusing on projects that I'd worked on
and kind of they were very like CMS in
focus in a lot of ways so that kind of
helped but I essentially you know
provided projects that I worked on and
said here's how this would frayed it to
what I would like to do with my Master's
but I would I would say don't worry too
much I think it'll be fine
if you have other specific questions so
I'm just wondering like [ __ ] out
looking pool all my visit mostly
undergrad signals are they're equally
split in the makeup of the classes ten
each ten students right the question
would serve someone who's been working
for a few years and wants them to get a
sense of what the mix is of the kinds of
applicants we get and it's a mix we
generally get fewer people straight out
of undergrad and those people who we
accept or shirt of undergrad are special
because they have a special sense of
direction and so on because often
there's a just a kind of mature
maturation as as as a scholar as an
intellect as an activist whatever you're
doing it comes with having a little
space in between so you know in many
ways you're at an advantage for having
done something between the two you know
um but I would say in your application
don't be wearing like how can I spin
this just say what you're interested in
what you want to do okay
yeah as far as the breakdown goes I will
say our cohort has quite a wide range
yeah yeah so on one hand we have Gordon
who has been working for many years and
we have a few other people who've been
working for years and then on the other
end we do have a few people who are
either I'm just out but then there are a
couple of that I've only had like one or
two years between undergrad and grad and
I would say the new cohort is a little
more skewed to the just like a couple of
years out of certain school age range
but he's still still married and when
any when we put together the class we're
seeking diversity on a variety of levels
and we like to have a cohort that you
know they're not all similar right they
all they're doing different kinds of
things and sometimes if we're debating
between two candidates it's not they're
both grade it's just their work is too
similar and which one can we pick which
you know which one is a better fit so we
really want to have an interesting range
of people
other questions and students research
and so the question was so we're looking
for people who come in who have already
sorted out their method what they want
to do and how they will do it I can
answer that but does anyone else want to
address it
whose we're here to learn things
together you know so if you there's no
reason for us to accept students who are
already really done you know they
already know all the answers they've all
sorted out everything and they're just
gonna you know check us off their list
or something we want them to come in and
experience new things and you know
you're if you really you came in without
enough background to even have a sense
of what's a method and why should I have
one it like that's your - wrong right
but if you come in and you're like not
sure what kind of method you want to use
while you're here well that's why we
have classes called theories and methods
one in theories and methods - that are
your core required classes to introduce
you to a variety of methods and get you
thinking about which one is the right
match for you and what how you want to
pursue it um and some people come in
already knowing I'm in Agra this is my
method this is my you know my research
questions and they pursue that or they
get here and they're like actually not
so much I really want to look at this
instead and so that that can happen -
and that's productive that's not like a
mistake that's a good thing because
you're learning and growing
I'll say add something to that which is
that is it is really valuable to you
know figure out before or in the process
of doing your application you know which
of the research groups you're most on to
that will you know that's you'll see
you'll have seen that's a question on
the application and it's important that
you not just kind of check it off and
say well this one sounds great but
really do some research on them so that
you can talk meaningfully in your
application about why what you want to
do might fit within schools of the
research groups yeah that's really
helpful and I think some people will
check off like all the research groups
don't you don't do that they think
they're being helpful like I'm so
flexible I like everything but actually
it's more helpful for us to you know
limit it and you know see really where
your where the best fit might be for you
know I just wanted to say also that we
are looking for people who have a strong
sense of direction and know what they
want to do when they come here but I
also think that if you asked the
students who have graduated that most of
them would agree that the years they
spend here is a deeply transformative
experience it might be in terms of which
methods you're using or a theoretical
framework but it could also be like on
the level of your worldview so I think
that's after all what we're aiming for
here to to create change in us as
persons and the scholars but that
doesn't mean we want to see you sense of
direction already when you apply yeah so
we have a few questions coming from the
our online participants do you want to
stand over here so to repeat your
question or just your shorter thanks hey
interwebs I'm the person who's answering
the chat the question was what does the
program look for in a candidate what
makes a strong candidate and a strong
application and especially they were
very concerned about GRE scores the
my guess that resonates my GRE scores in
math are not very good I'm sympathetic
to those people you know but um we don't
have a numeric cutoff like this is the
GRE you know and I believe the scores
come in with percentages yes yes um what
percentage err so that's very helpful
for me when I'm looking at applicants
I'm like if you're in the bottom 30% in
your verbal skills that's a red flag
that you know you don't have the skills
that you're gonna need here
um but once we get above a percent or so
I'm like okay you you may be a poor
tester you may not be good at these
standardized tests and so on and so
forth so there's no hard like this is
the number where we cut off on GREs we
do see your GPA as an undergrad and you
know that's relevant you know if you're
a straight C students you're probably
not a good applicant for us and you
might say oh you all might be thinking
I'm here because I'm a straight-a
student that's great but you know we get
a range of napkins so so there's a level
on which numbers matter you submit a
writing sample and that is something
people ask a lot of questions about what
are you looking for in a writing sample
and it's great when a writing sample
feels like a really strong match with
what we do here in terms of the topic
area um but at least when I'm reading
them I'm also thinking you know who's a
good writer who can really express him
or herself well and so if I get a
writing sample on debussy without a
technical angle of like modern
incarnations to do you know it doesn't
seem directly relevant to our transmedia
project
I don't automatically go well that's not
really right I look at well what's the
writing what's the argumentation style
try to be flexible about the topic if
you have something that's very relevant
to us that's great but some people have
a sort of finite group of undergraduate
papers and they're like this doesn't
seem exactly right but it shows how I
express myself great sin
send that in so hopefully that that
helps a little bit I don't know if
anyone who has anything to add is yeah I
hear the sort of an elaboration of that
I'll sure I seem to remember that when I
was doing the application now like a
couple years ago there was a space where
I could put in like links to additional
portfolios and work and I think I sent
links to some of the journalistic
articles and I'm wondering if I think
there's still space where people can
submit like artistic work or design
portfolio or maybe even a tech portfolio
and that's something that's looked at
also yeah that can be very useful to see
well this person is doing interesting
podcasts or they have a blog or just to
get a sense again of how they express
themselves and so on yeah that's still
part of the application process and I
can be very handy I think in general we
you know we look at all these all the
different elements of the application
you know quite holistically there's no
one thing yeah but certainly certainly
as we as we've said that we're looking
for people who have some some clarity of
direction in terms of why they've chosen
to go to graduate school why they've
chosen this particular school and and
having a clarity the clarity of a
project that that person wants to pursue
is also you know really important thing
to see even if people have said even if
once they're here it might go in other
directions now add this as a question
students often have in Shannon can you
help me with this um of the not the the
recommendation letters there's a certain
number that need to be scholarly versus
we like it if they're if they're all
Scotland yeah but if you if that means
you're calling up someone that you
haven't
class with since freshman year and they
probably can't remember you don't use
that person use you know someone who
knows you well and can really respond to
your ability to succeed in graduate
school yeah so we we like all the
recommendation letters to be scholarly
but if there's one there from you know
you were just a journalist and
interesting working magazine or
newspaper and your boss writes a good
letter for you like that's fine that's a
nice part of the of a package but we
wouldn't want all the letters to be from
that direction in most cases there might
be some exceptions but that's kind of
rule of thumb
Kurt vent just came in do you mind we
have where we're live here and we can
only really hear people there standing
in the area of this microphone would you
guys mind coming back here and introduce
yourselves
and this is one of our grad students
who's working in the lab with Kurt I yes
I am so why don't we just turn it off so
that we're not although I like the
spotlight
I don't want to okay great
welcome it's great to see so many of you
interested in in in CMS so my name is
Kurt vent I direct hyper studio digital
humanities at MIT and that's I'm having
a first year student and one of my lab
is Cypress video yeah exactly so we want
to briefly talk about you know five
minutes yeah what hacker studio does and
also how a graduate student an RA in
micro studio is involved in the work
that we do so primarily hyper studio
deals and explores the ways digital
technologies impact the way we do
research and we teach and learn in the
humanities arts and social sciences so
that's basically the the framework for
that as part of that we work with
faculty at MIT and other universities
outside we also have international
collaborations on projects that explore
on the one
and on a scholarly basis how can we
rethink how we do research one of the
projects for example is with Jeff rebel
here in in this building he's in history
is a professor of theatre history French
theatre history so it's exploring how
the ticket sales of the Comedie
Francaise which was the major theatre in
in France was the troupe of the King how
they built their repertory and is really
looking after ticket sales from 1680 on
how decisions were shaped by influences
from the political side from you know
the the creative side and so on so we
build tools that allow that but also
engage you know the international
audience of scholars into into that
project some of these projects are
ongoing for a very long time and we've
had many graduate students and Ras
involved in this project looking at data
visualization doing other kinds of
research so that's one of the
possibilities another project that we do
in the educational realm is a project
that's called annotation studio and that
looks at digital aspects collaborative
community aspects of clothes weeding and
how this is shaped by a social
environment in which students go very
deep into a text it could be a media
text right now it's primarily written
text but it will be media text field
fairly soon and how to make connections
to other texts for example when you read
Moby Dick or any other literary text of
course they are a precursor text you
want to make connections to those there
are implementations and adaptations in
different kinds of media you want to
link to those so it really brings up a
different understanding of a text and
you know how this could be read and
shared and and used for interpretation
in a different way so this is these are
just two of the projects that we work on
and it's always a code is
approach we work with faculty very
closely and I'm sure you've heard about
co.design you know which is a very
important aspect that we do faculty are
involved in the team the developers are
involved the RAS are involved in the
team and this is really important we
look at the actual need that faculty use
students or other scholars have in this
project and then we decide you know
what's the best approach to do that it's
never that the technology is at the
forefront you know technology comes in
we use open source technology our
technology is open source and so on so
that's we do that in in a range of
different projects right now we have
four or five five ongoing projects right
now like always you know there are
different stages and we also teach a
class in digital humanities and we
contribute to other classes right and
one of the graduate students or you know
depending on next year might be more you
know are also involved
stas in this class we have an outreach
you know we do occasionally talks
workshops and so on and we have a weekly
newsletter which you know it's called h
plus d insights and this is a great
newsletter because it basic gives you
know sort of our perspective on digital
humanities what's going on and right now
they're about 700 subscribers to to that
newsletter so it's it's a really great
and the newsletter is always done by one
of the graduate students so I'll hand it
over to Evan so he can talk about what
he's working on I also have to go so
thank you for thanking you all and and
any specific questions feel free to
email me so yeah I work on a couple
different projects that hyper studio the
main project that I spend most my time
working on
is a sort of a collaboration with it one
of the writing professors so like the W
and the C MSW and his name his name's
Ken Manning and he writes a bla mostly
about like african-american scientists
and so he said this he said this archive
day he's been collecting over the past
few decades of biographical records of
black medical professionals from 1860 to
1980 and it's it's like at this point
it's it's up to 23,000 different
specific doctors and they have all this
great like associated material that is
like correspondents unpublished works
autobiographies like this whole treasure
trove of content and so so Ken really
wanted to get that content out there for
scholars and and just let people just
start looking through and using in their
own work and so I think I was you know
very early on assigned to this project
when I first came in but the great thing
about working half in hyper studio is
that we can we can use a lot of the
hyper studio tools and resources for
this content to create like sort of a
online archive for it and and yeah so
this is what I've been spending most of
my time doing and as far as like what I
actually do in terms of concrete things
it's just sort of like three different
categories I do I spend a lot of time
doing research like down in the archives
looking through the different documents
and cataloging them and getting to know
them and getting familiar with I also
spend a lot of time thinking about the
what the final products where this will
be what the the archive will be how a
function who's going to use it what
they're gonna need to access how they're
going to need to access it and then also
just doing sort of promotional work like
right now I'm writing a blog post about
it we've applied for a conference
presentation about this this resource so
yeah as far as like what my actual time
in lab is done it's sort of a
combination of those three things mm-hmm
thank you um do you guys have some
questions for them or more generally
I had an upgrade so this is a question
that I guess is directed at everyone but
maybe perhaps mostly for the currently
enrolled students certainly I'm really
intrigued in a way that CMS is bringing
together a diverse range approaches to
mediate diverse approaches diverse labs
I'm wondering it there and there's
certainly a lot of collaborative
opportunities within CMS so the program
and I'm wondering if those collaborative
opportunities also resonate across MIT
as a broader organization certainly
youth this you mentioned earlier the
ways in which there are opportunities
people to get involved with the
communities here in Cambridge in Boston
right so jeffrey asks you know we
collaborate a lot within it within CMS
but what are the opportunities to
collaborate across MIT and outside of
MIT and you know beyond yeah I think
people do that in different ways it is
it's one of those things where you it
helps to have a sense of the people with
whom you might want to collaborate
beforehand it's a large institution
people are doing especially at the
graduate level like very different work
people don't like they institution-wide
people may not necessarily always be
familiar with what's happening in each
program I know from my own experience I
am one of my so we have when we do our
thesis work we choose a committee and
one of my thesis one of my committee
members one of my advisors is actually
somebody who runs a group in the media
which is kind of a neighboring program
to us but is actually not the same
program and is more engineering driven
so that's an example of how and that
that evolved really naturally from
mutual interests he was looking at
issues and topics related to news and we
became familiar with each other's work
and so that that happened really like
that was a really good partnership I
know other people have also taken that
Avenue asked professors from other
departments to serve on their advising
committees in other ways as well trying
to think I really have anything to add
to that it's definitely a very
individual decision most
the people that I've interacted with
outside of the department I've met at
lectures or conferences in town and you
know just having similar conversations
in a same spot and making a connection
that way as far as like working on a
collaborative project it's mostly been
CMS driven for me but that's not like a
choice I've made it's just kind of how
it's organically happened yeah I'm glad
you mentioned all the talks because you
know yeah I mean one doesn't go to talks
at Harvard like every day Tom's here
every day Microsoft Research is an
amazing resource nearby where they have
talked so much many different analysis
yeah your departments enterpreneur
Society up at Harvard and so you might
spend you know one day go to talk on
algorithms at Microsoft Research then I
hope to Berkman to learn about
surveillance then back to Microsoft to
learn about comics then over here to
learn about Japanese music we had a
colloquium on that you know so there's
so many opportunities in a way you you
come in so like stay ambitious it's good
to come in and fishes but then you
realize like there's only so much I can
do in two years and so you sort out like
okay I'm just gonna collaborate this
small way as opposed to you know and I
think also as part of the all research
groups of course have collaborations
with we're with different groups and you
know international collaborations so
that's where it comes in as well yeah
you might be doing a conference
internationally through a research group
or you might be building a product for
Mitsubishi and the mobile experience lab
or you know there's all kinds of
different ways that you're reaching
outside of the Institute yeah or just
just the project I was just talking
about is what someone who's sort of
outside of CMS proper yeah okay he's on
the W so I mean I haven't really
experienced this yet but I have to
imagine electives it's a big way that
you can sort of like get outside of the
CMS bubble but also get outside of the
MIT bubble and take classes at Harvard
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
when it comes to the game lab I think
most people here don't think of it this
is CMS they
most of our undergraduate researchers
are from course six for instance so
which is course it's your science
Electrical Engineering electronics yes
so we do have that sort of mix of
different kinds of skill sets that is
needed for the types of projects with
you and we we collaborate a lot with
with outside interests so if you're an
already for us you will be expected to
probably travel both in North America
and Europe with to follow our different
projects and get sent to different
conferences other questions yeah imagine
you were working I think the question
was about the creative communities
initiative and you can fill us in but
ian is supposed to he has a meet he had
a class at rental three and then a
meeting at 3:30 so any second now he may
rush in and give a quick presentation of
his ok but while you can I will
explanation is one of the newer research
groups and the two primary professors
are Ian Condry who is an anthropologist
and tal Taylor who was mentioned before
she is a sociologist and Ian's work has
been mostly with he wrote a book on
Japanese hip-hop and the soul of Annie
Mae hi Carrie this is Curia called well
she's also a graduate student yeah she's
mentioned before yeah so CCI is this we
basically focus on ethnographic work and
I will take a moment so it was mentioned
that placement for research groups is
which we do they do that very carefully
and that is mostly because so usually
you end up in a place where you have
experience but I for one didn't have
much ethnographic experience before but
it did turn out to be a great fit but I
just wanted to put in a plug that most
people end up in a place that they
expect sometimes you don't but it'll be
great so CCI is focusing on ethnographic
work this weekend I
going with the group to San Jose to a
conference to do some ethnographic work
last year we did a collaboration with
BabyCenter which was this online
platform for mothers mostly mothers but
for parents and so it's kind of a little
all over the board but we'd also do
really great things like we have guest
lectures we have a guest lecture coming
today which I'll have to duck out for
soon and we do we do readings together
which has been very helpful for me
especially since I didn't have that
ethnographic kind of background okay
thank you
um kiri a call though one of our grad
students just came in and so did Ethan
Zuckerman are you uh on a tight schedule
that you were to Russia
okay so let's maybe Curia can just
introduce yourself as a grad student
quickly and then Ethan do you have your
computer because you want to hook up no
no no but actually I'd like to fir you
didn't and then we'll have some more
questions uh hi I'm cari Cole Cole um so
CMS grad soon and second year with here
and I work for the MIT game lab and the
education arcade for my RA ship so I run
around talking and talking about playing
promoting in like kind of a cultural
like let's have fun playing games kind
of way so yeah I actually just got out
of doing a lecture for one of our
courses or one of the courses that at
least is take a bowl here on gender and
gender in Japanese games so so I was
just talking about so sorry if I seem a
little frazzled I've been hopping from
teaching to teaching switch that class
is also taught by Ed contract by the way
I think all of this gives you a sense of
the pacing of things around
oh yes well Ethan is walking over one
more Internet question yes alright hello
out there can you talk more about the
program's balance between theory and
practice for those of us who are
especially interested in the creative
side of new media is it possible for a
thesis proposal to be centered around a
creative project in the game lab for an
example right talk about the
relationships between theory and
practice for example could a thesis be
sent around a game lab project could you
speak to that as a game lab yes so we
definitely have those kind of sort of
thesis projects not just in the game but
also in the eyes and so on so we often
do some kind of combination of what
you're doing is an artistic expression
but it also always has to have some kind
of research question that you're
exploring through that word so it can't
just be a fine arts project but it's
very often some kind of balance between
the two I do when I have something no I
think I think that that's very helpful
and we you know it sort of happens on a
case-by-case basis you know what is the
balance between the creative output you
want to do and the research questions
that you're pursuing we actually have
two second-year master students working
on their theses right now that are doing
creative projects and I want to kind of
put the plug in that if you do a
creative project you still have to
create the thesis that has some sort of
theoretical framework so it's a delicate
balance but I think they both are very
happy to be doing creative work as well
yeah and if I were advising someone one
of those CCS that would be like be
careful not to bite off more than you
can chew because you can't actually
design a whole new thing you know and
write on your face pieces and you know
you so and often the thesis meeting it's
like limit yourself limit yourself and
pull it in a little bit yeah Ethan could
you come over at where we're live here
and no one can see you if you're sitting
there
absolutely um I could just bid
disembodied voice you're just trying to
force me to put my laptop down how do
you I mean from Zukerman I direct a
research group that's part of CNS called
Center for civic media it's a group
that's got participants both from the
Media Lab
as well as from the CMS program so right
now I actually have four graduate
students from the Media Lab I have two
graduate students from CMS that's a
pretty typical ratio for us I should
probably start with this weird term
civic media for us Civic media is this
idea that you can make social change by
making and disseminating media and
putting it out in the world for us that
often means digital media and
particularly participatory media so
making social media making blogs putting
on videos but we see Civic media really
much more broadly it's the whole art of
making media and looking at the ways in
which that might make change in the
world so some of the work that we do is
around building platforms so you can see
some of the work that we do online if
you'd like one of the things that we
released recently is called fold it's at
fold dot CM and this is basically a
novel form of publishing and content
management system it's basically a way
of going after a problem that we're
seeing a lot of in online publishing
which is that despite the fact that
there's so many things you can do a text
online mostly people treat web pages as
newspaper columns they run text they
break it up with an image they run text
then they have a diagram and then they
run some more text and it's not actually
a particularly good way to read or write
it doesn't take very much advantage of
the power of the medium and the use of
the hyperlink so we design sort of a new
platform based around the idea that you
have eyes that move not just up and down
but left and right and you're writing in
an environment where there's an enormous
amount of rich information that you can
link to and embed
otherwise create so fold is a nice
example of where someone might go with
master's thesis this was a student over
at the Media Lab she did this as a
master's thesis in design we were able
to pair her with a programmer to make
sure that this actually launched during
her time at the program the two of them
have now formed a company and are now
taking venture capital and are trying to
figure out is this a competitor to
something like medium or is this
something that might be useful you know
for instance in a newsroom or in
scientific publishing something along
those lines one of my current students
from CMS is now in his second year in
his thesis here his project is called
deep stream and this is basically a way
of trying to add some context to live
video streams so it's sort of a similar
model so one branch what we do is
platforms a second branch of what we do
might be thought of as crowdsourcing
community data so we do a lot of work in
the field right now our major field site
of Sao Paulo Brazil and we're doing a
lot of work helping small community
organizations make maps of urban
infrastructure's and the idea behind
this is we're really interested in the
question of how do you let citizens feel
powerful and actually have change over
their local environments and so this
often means working at a city level
rather than a federal level and it often
means it almost always means letting the
community that you're working with tell
you what issues are most important so
we're going and working with sort of
established community groups they're
identifying issues of urban
infrastructure in their communities
we've been building a software platform
that allows large teams of people to
collect photos and videos to geo locate
them put them on a map and produce
datasets that they can use for advocacy
and that work is now getting combined
with work with sensors we've just been
building a low-cost audio sensor we're
starting to do a noise map of Cambridge
what this Cambridge sound like at
different times of day what are the
quiet and the noisy spots and that's
really a framework that's going to let
us use a much
richer set of sensors around air
pollution and water pollution going
forward the third thing we work on is
you mind if I push the pause button on
yeah just a second great without your
computer by the way but Ian it's not a
really tight schedule the third point
and then I will get out of the way for
you and Bob to grab the rest okay third
thing for me I do a lot of work on media
impact so a lot of people in the social
change field want to know if they make
media and put it out in the world what
sort of effect is it having when Occupy
introduced the idea of the 99% of the 1%
what influence did it have when black
lives matter or went out and essentially
said racism isn't over in fact it's
something we have to be actively working
on what impacts has that had we have a
project that's been going on for eight
years that's called media cloud you
might think of it as LexisNexis only
open source and focused on digital media
and it's optimized so that we can map
online conversations when people are
talking about a controversial issue
what's the language that they're using
and when activists are getting involved
with that issue and trying to introduce
new language how successful are they
with it and I'd love to tell you more
about it but for now I want to hand over
to dr. Ian country and the wonderful
projects that he does thank you
Thank You Heather yeah so I'm Ian
Condrey I'm a cultural anthropologist
here at MIT I've been here 12 years
camera there's a camera there some
anthropologists and I we have a lab
called the creative communities
initiative
it's TL Taylor and I she's a sociologist
I'm an anthropologist we're both
interested in ethnography doing
fieldwork participant observation as a
way of understanding connections between
online and offline worlds and their
potential their potential to bring new
solutions to old problems
that's our tagline but basically the
notion is that it grows out of my own
research and tiel's research as well I
look at Jack
popular culture how cultural movements
spread globally my first project was on
hip hop in Japan how does rap music take
root in Japan my second book was about
Japanese animation how did Japanese
animation become a global phenomenon and
part of my conclusion was that at the
beginning of sort of both of these
cultural forms elites didn't get it they
didn't think this is going to be
important it wasn't going to go anywhere
even in the u.s. hip hop at first was
seen this is not music they're not even
singing they don't play instruments this
is not going to go anywhere and yet
communities of passionate committed
people gradually grew audiences worked
on the forums spread them around found
ways to connect to other communities and
that change often comes from the margins
into the center so the idea is how do
you find those communities that are
going to bring about change
I think fieldwork and being among those
groups is a way to do it that in fact if
you spend time with people if you spend
time in these spaces you can see what
has a kind of positive energy a forward
momentum a potential to reach across the
boundaries that are out there already so
that's the idea behind the creative
communities initiative I'm currently
working on music and the way music is
recovering and a really a vibrant space
despite the impossibility of making
money on recordings that the prediction
was music would disappear it hasn't it's
actually gotten more vibrant in the
years since the recording industry has
plummeted and yet new ways new kinds of
business and social connectivity has
really made it a very interesting space
so that's my future project TL is
working on eSports and various kinds of
online gaming communities we have
students working on a variety of things
Laci is one of our students working on
interactive comics and how that's
shaking up the comics world we've had
people studying videogames in Peru and
how that got going diversity in the tech
sector
ghost workers in Africa is actually a
kind of interesting intersection of
politics and economics and cultural
settings that one of our students is
working on as well so there's a lot of
possibilities and basically our focus is
finding ways to use fieldwork and
ethnography to understand Media Studies
issues in more detail and really open up
the discussion of how change happens by
looking at communities and being part of
them in some way thank you
that's the pitch if you have one or two
questions I'd be happy to take any
questions no prob thank you all right
there I'm so glad you like to run to a
lab meeting no I just wanted to say
though if anybody would has more
questions for me please email me or our
emails are up on the site yeah yeah you
can go to a page of all the students um
whew
they say that MIT is like a firehose of
knowledge right so we're giving you the
fire oh my god so much maybe if anyone
has any questions for Ethan oh we could
back up maybe just say one last thing
which is just sort of the work that
people have ended up some of that work
ends up focusing on building so my
current CMS second year student Gordon
Mangum is doing the design work and a
lot of the engineering on deep stream
which is a pretty serious software
engineering project a lot of the work
that people do with me is more
traditional sort of cultural studies or
communication settings so two of the
sort of highlight standout theses the
last two years
last year Chelsea Barrabas wrote a
thesis with me about the technology
pipeline and the ways in which gender
and race were playing into under
representation within Silicon Valley
hiring culture and that's actually work
that's been quite influential on the
sort of foundation and social change
community the Ford Foundation and
abusing it it's part of their jumping
off or some of the work that they're
using in this space she is now working
for the MIT Media Lab leading research
on questions of equity and equality
within digital currency because
big lava weather focused on Bitcoin just
interject that she's at the colloquium
at five o'clock so ask her all about
yeah two years before that the standard
thesis was from Molly Sauter who did
work on denial of service attacks as a
form of protected political speech this
was really fun I have done a lot of the
work on how denial of service attacks
served to censor and silenced dissident
and human rights organizations in the
developing world so you would think that
I would be the least likely person to be
supportive on a thesis about the ways in
which these might be viewed as political
speech but she was real persuasive and
real persistent and wrote an amazing
book out of her thesis called the coming
swarm which she got published within six
months of graduation she's now in a
doctoral program in Canada so people go
in all sorts of really interesting
directions from this but they go very
very impressive in very cool places
thank you from the internet do you have
projects at the intersection between
international development and media and
is that something that will be a new fit
for CMS projects the intersection of
international development and media oh
yeah you bet so I've been running a
website for 11 years called Global
Voices and one of the cofounders of it
which is basically an international news
wire of stories coming from the
developing world a lot of our work right
now is sort of analyzing and
understanding how media coverage in the
developing world does and doesn't
penetrate into mainstream media coverage
we did a little bit of work on attention
to the Charlie Hebdo attacks versus
attacks in Baga Nigeria at the same
period of time that the New York Times
actually cited the public editors cited
in talking about deciding to change
their coverage and pay more attention to
terrorism on a global
so we have actually a lot of folks in
our lab come in from a development
background Gordon who's working on deep
stream actually has been doing media
training in the developing world for the
last four or five years Chelsea who is
now doing this work on Bitcoin actually
came from an international development
background and some of the side projects
that people end up working on not even
though thesis projects end up being very
strongly connected to this a project
that Chelsea and a student named Jude
malenda worked on last year was in using
unmanned aerial vehicles drones armed
with infrared cameras to detect charcoal
being made in forests in Kenya so
charcoal is like people think charcoal
it's funny like charcoal is a super huge
problem in sub-saharan Africa and the
way that you make it is you clear-cut
trees you dig a big hole you put the
trees and you light them on fire and you
bury your earth on top of them and what
you really want to do is find people
making this and arrest them and one of
the best ways to do it is to find active
fires and it turns out that you can do
it by heat signature and while it sounds
crazy to be using drones in Kenya it
turns out that drones are the cutting
edge for what people do to spot wildlife
to take rich Americans out on game
drives so what you do is you take the
same drones that people are flying
during the day to figure out where the
Lions are you put a different camera and
different software on top of it and you
start identifying where the charcoal is
and you go after the poachers so yeah we
work on fun stuff Sarah are you Sarah
wolven is out in the hallway are you
ready for us sir questions directly for
you Sarah awesome and she she great
she's from the open documentary lab or
open dock with two students who work
with her too so um if you want to sit
here and if the students could could you
guys we're on we're live streaming so we
can see each other they can see it's
best if you stand behind us any
you're out yeah you wanna you understand
all right for the open documentary lab
we look at new forms of storytelling and
look at the intersection of Technology
storytelling how they change each other
we're also looking at institutions we
just came out with a report yesterday
about how legacy institutions are making
the transition in digital work using
experimental and collaborative works
that interactive documentaries do we
also we build resources when we started
the lab it was 2012 there was really no
infrastructure for this very new type of
story telling and so we brought together
curators and funders and technologists
and storytellers all to really think
about what does this field need and
where do we fit in one of the things
we've started to do is build resources
so the first thing we did was a project
called moments of innovation which
looked at the whole history of
nonfiction storytelling and showed that
all these new processes we talked about
interactive participatory data and
mersive have long histories and that
when you think about a documentary you
really were unattach it to an actual
medium so it's not film it's not
photography it's many different media
put together and it can come from
anywhere and so when for instance we
look at data storytelling we go back to
cave paintings and what they did there
so our participatory has a long process
of you know we start with the Kodak
camera and how that changed the ability
for people to take their own photos and
changed you in what the notion of what a
photo is so we do a lot of projects like
that the other one we have is docu base
which is a database that's tracking the
people technologies and projects that
are transforming documentary in the
digital age we put out a we collect
documentaries put them out there we have
case studies the students work on we
have playlists to help you guide you
through it we have a lab section that
does all these behind the scenes to open
up the process of what this new kind of
filmmaking is not filmmaking this
documentary making and what we're
finding too is it's requiring entirely
new teams entirely new relationships
with audiences and subjects which we no
longer call audiences and subjects and
it's just really rethinking what
storytelling is what the role of the
author is you know that you're creating
a place for conversation that you're
creating a process as opposed to a
product that you're having different
kinds of impacts than you would with
just putting a film out there so those
are the kind of things we're looking at
we have a lot going on we partner with a
lot of Film Institute's with Tribeca
Institute we're doing a media impact
project with Sundance we have several
projects but one we send students to
Sundance every year to write about this
new type of storytelling try to get it
out in the public with info and a
documentary festival in Amsterdam we do
other projects so a lot of collaborating
to is different institutions thank you
thank you and so we have two students
who are in participating this lab of
course you're in it yeah sure so I can
talk a little bit about my motivations
for joining this lab actually my
background is in producing I knew our
student oh yes and my name is so my
background is in producing public
affairs documentaries mostly for PBS you
know linear broadcast very traditional
and so I was really interested in
opendoc lab as a way to explore other
forms of storytelling other platforms
their creative approaches and to really
meet people who are working in this
field
I'm Dennis Thornton I'm a second year
CMS student also with Oakland Dog Club
and my background is in film in both
like I'm fiction I'm fiction film or
like
with our tops and I don't know I think
it's a pretty great lab what you get to
do is you go to Sundance right for
indieWIRE or like what's doing case
studies last here especially on pieces
like I did one on like a VR piece called
a scent and like of that documentary
called do-not-track so it consists of
basically doing the in-depth study like
interviews and research and writing and
it is very rewarding and right now I'm
researching virtual reality and
nonfiction and it's kind of like looking
at the convergence of games and
documentary and also looking at new 3d
capture technologies and how it changes
how you make media for like looking at
360 video and its relation to nonfiction
so yeah if you have any background in
like media making or film or a
documentary in any form I think it would
be a great thank you
we open up wait just hang on all right I
want to make sure everyone in the room
has their so I would say that we've got
you know two or three long-term projects
and lots of shorter term projects so
first of all every student ends up with
her own project either for the thesis or
often something that that sure he will
end up so doing on on one's own the
longer projects tend to have staff
members attached to them so we're mostly
grant funded and so for instance on the
media cloud work where you know we've
been doing that for eight years there's
now a staff team of like five or six
people on that and when students are
coming in we're helping you find a
manageable bite-sized chunk
that's sort of playing to your skill set
and interests and you're sort of getting
ramped up by the rest of that team for
projects that are more speculative like
promise tracker where I haven't gotten
anyone to really figure out how to pay
for it and part because we started
working in Brazil another Brazilian
economy collapsed it was not my best
move we are often sort of scratching for
funding instead of finding it in
interesting places and then students in
many cases may be sort of building at
the same time as we are so there were
two CMS students involved with sort of
our vs. trip to Sao Paulo
doing the interviewing were considered
designing the protocols and sort of
doing our first sort of community
projects there so sometimes it's in the
startup phase sometimes it's in the
inheritance fades but it is the
inheritance phase it's almost always in
a case where we have a certain amount of
institutional knowledge from a staff
team that's on board and able to help
out
it's the helpful um maybe another room
and then we can do it yeah like this
when replying already carrying some
projects with this nine we have multiple
choices but we have been working for a
while and there will be arcing to and
scholar sources and organizations we
have been working with will we be able
to bring in this project well while we
are collectively joining opponents
Wow that's an interesting question did
you had left - okay all right could you
repeat the question yeah sure so the
question was for people who are already
interested in applying to CMS and have
projects that they want to do how does
that sort of interact with what they do
in the lab and I think one thing that's
interesting and worth mentioning cuz I
had the same question when I was
applying is that many students don't do
their thesis work in partnership with
the labs some do where there's a really
like strong overlap or you know it makes
sense from an agenda perspective but
it's also very doable to do your thesis
alongside your lab work it is I mean
it's both are significant commitments
but that's what I'm doing for a fact
like my thesis which looks at news
organizations and like comment spaces is
quite it's quite different from my lab
work in the design lab and that's fine
and in your case you came in with a very
clear knowledge of what you wanted to do
you were in my office a week and that
doesn't always happen but it does
sometimes so I would say maybe there's
three things that could end up happening
it's possible to come here with a
project and have an align very closely
with a group and have the group say
that's great let's do this and let's
give you resources and work together on
it's possible to come up come in with a
project and have it be you know
ideologically aligned with a group you
know that's why we would put you in a
group but it's your project and you
might end up working on it for the
thesis and the group might not end up
working on it the third which in some
ways I think might actually be the most
likely is that you come here with a
project and you may discover that
there's other things you want to work on
too and and that is one of the
interesting things here I mean generally
speaking people don't get into programs
like this one unless you are already
doing some very very interesting work
but a whole lot of people come here with
very very interesting work and then find
a whole other set of things to get
interested in so I don't think it should
be a barrier
unless you're sort of insistent that you
want to be in Group one in which case
you'd really want to be very certain
that you were working with a group that
that was excited about picking up your
project and running with it and and
that's hard to guarantee you know folks
like Heather and me are pretty
opinionated and we have the projects if
we want to work out we're excited about
and yeah we're swayable sometimes
sometimes Thank You Shannon
you were gonna do an online question
would you mind standing over here just
so I don't have to repeat or this is
mostly bouncing off of Sarah although I
think other people might have some as
well the first question was what if
you're coming in and you're purely
documentary is this the right program
and if if so why and the other one was
sort of the opposite end of that is if
what if you want to work with open doc
lab do you have to have made a
documentary in order to do so yeah
answer the second question first
no you don't at all you just have to
have an interest and usually though you
have some skills something that's
aligned with documentary making so that
the first question if you're a
documentary purist so I mean I would
have to find out what they mean by that
yeah but for us we're rethinking the
documentary and we you know support
linear documentary we think it's great
but it's not what we're working on and
studying and there are master's programs
that are strictly in documentary
filmmaking and if you're certain that
you really don't want to study the
history of X Y or Z or take a class
called major media text or take a class
called theories and methods one and two
because you have certain documentaries
that you want to be you know then maybe
a documentary filmmaking program that's
a better match for you so I'm not saying
no to this person don't apply I'm just
saying you need to be open and flexible
and interested in all kinds of things
that are happening around here even if
you happen to be more directed and
the area yeah yeah back to you anyone
out there did you want to come in and
take a seat you're in the door there's a
seat up here for you like yeah the
question was if you have something for
your portfolio you want to include
online like a link to a webpage or
something and it's not in English is it
disqualified no it's not just qualified
but if we don't speak your language
we're not going to get much out of it so
you know bear that in mind
yes yes it's Jerry's course submitted
last year still in the system
yeah GREs are their scores are valid for
five years and I guess it's part of the
question if one is applied before yes if
you've already submitted your scores to
MIT or and they are still valid I still
have them and you don't have to send
them again nice very good thank you
are there students who for example
maintain a full-time job or are able to
sort of juggle sort of maintaining
institutional ties in other places while
the emeritus program of externally if
you are cyborg it's long you have no
sleep needs really people don't come in
who are also working full-time job
somewhere else it's very very intense
kind of experience you know
theoretically 20 hours a week in a lab
but it can bleed over it can be more
sometimes at certain moments you've got
your classwork
you've got a very very full plate here I
think that for us when we were thinking
about it for first semester our
commitments with lab and coursework and
everything came to usually and reading
and all that in the first semester came
to between like 50 and 70 hours a week
it was a lot so doing yeah doing a
full-time job on top of that like you'd
have to
but as far as other affiliations we did
have a student who graduated last year
who was very involved with running an
annual Film Festival mm-hmm and so that
was something that he was able to do a
few hours a week and then sort of stop
and take a few days to sort of go work
on that and yeah he needed a little
extra time to graduate he went over into
the summer but it was not impossible but
that was definitely not a full-time job
but that question of sort of if you have
another affiliation a volunteer project
that's very important to you someone
like that that's feasible but another
job while you do this is well yeah
there's a section tons of the
application for test scores in there a
series of open boxes to place
information about your resume about
relevant travel experience what are
those fields for how much space is
appropriate to use I mean I could write
volumes about those things but they're
also present when other elements of the
applications are left what do you hope
to see in those open form sections of
the application Shannon is that
something you can answer just because
you've got the form memorized better
than I do
yeah I just kind of read the end product
if it's something that shows up in
another part of the application don't
bother repeating it because the the
committee has already seen it
they really do read these applications
very thoroughly the open spaces are
primarily for something that doesn't
fall into the other boxes so something
extra something or something that you
want to really highlight that you did
something exceptional about you that's
pretty much what they're for
does that help okay thanks or the
financial be all yes
yes you mentioned that he says he might
be working on to be separate from your
lab work you also mentioned a thesis
committee I'm just wondering like when
you're working on your thesis and you're
looking for people to help advice we're
guide you or just collaborate with do
that usually I'll notice the student we
we do help you as director of Graduate
Studies I am meeting with students to
gauge their progress hey I need to meet
with you guys uh but uh so someone comes
in to meet with me and I say hey what's
your thesis gonna be on and this X Y or
Z and I said well who are you thinking
of working with and typically people
have a pretty good idea like you know
like Ethan would be perfect how many
students is he already have you work out
the logistics is it viable have you
talked to him yet if you don't do it's
office hours whatever but and then we
want to get your committee together
which is typically just one second
person with a CMS affiliation right
Shannon we don't they have we asked for
one person to be one of our regular CMS
right sometimes the second person is
outside so you might have someone from
history or urban studies who didn't have
a direct affiliation but you're the
director of the of your project would be
a primary yeah and sometimes no the
University but that's less colonist
encouraged but yet it can happen yeah
and this is something that faculty here
take very seriously and you know one of
the things we've actually been working
on us of ensuring that faculty have a
manageable number of people that they're
working with because it really is a
commitment I mean I'm meeting with my
thesis students weekly when they're in
the thesis here and you know working on
writing week by week as it's going
forward so it is a very close
relationship yeah
that's good question also I just add to
that um sometimes it can very much come
out of your lab work so I ended up
coming in and having like strong kind of
illogical ties as we were mentioning
with the game labs so I'm actually
working with Mikaela carry on my thesis
and that kind of happened
serendipitously through doing lab work
so you know you could even have like
strong ideas coming in like oh I want to
work it so and so and then you know that
might shift around as you start kind of
developing your ideas and your your work
outside and how that ends up influencing
all parts of your life right things
evolve organically uh-huh yeah there was
a question in the back yes how important
is it that you're applying to and
identify your research interests and how
they might with CMS's program person to
research okay so Jesse asks about you
know when you're applying and you're
thinking about your application do you
want to be thinking about your alignment
with CMS as a whole or versus a research
group um I I would say CMS as you're you
know thinking about organically what we
do as as a whole that said in some cases
you know if you are clearly you know
documentaries very strongly your focus
the way you sort of pitch yourself might
be strongly influenced by the fact that
you've studied what opendoc lab is and
you know you know about it but given um
given that as you take classes your
interests might shift a little bit we
want to bring in someone who's open to
all the possibilities of CMS all the
different things that are going on you
know to just pitch yourself as like I'm
a hyper studio person I think would be
too limiting
so I think it's better to think about
CMS kind of more holistically as a as a
kind of rule of thumb yeah sure
but one more out here this deceptive
cover summer but think I did not they're
all what used to fly it or some distress
there's the stipend cover summer funding
and if not are there opportunities there
are Shannon you can probably answer that
a little better than I can
as a practical I don't think as a rule
no the the stipend does not cover to
cover
summer funding some research groups have
funding and they will work if you're a
thesis on the research group are very
closely aligned and they have funding
they can offer you a summer RA but there
are also funds at the Institute that you
can apply for for summer research
funding right which is so that funding
to say travel somewhere could you know
work as opposed to just a monthly living
stipend correct kind of application yeah
so in short there are opportunities that
we don't have anything guaranteed for
your summer yeah anyone else in the room
because we can go to the internet
Shannon wants us to read the Internet
you're so good to take care of it
thank you
well proposing a project that is bigger
than the scope of the program be
detrimental sure like well okay look
there are big questions like I'm
interested in how technological internet
interventions can you know improve
health care
well that's huge right and then
something specific like how can data
sensors test air quality to see whether
you know people are people with us with
asthma are you know what they're getting
into their system you know that's a very
narrow question so obviously if your
research question is too broad then
we'll you know you don't you haven't
thought about it enough you don't have
enough focus you haven't did we've done
a deep dive yet um I don't know if
there's anyone else who could answer
that better have like specific examples
of students and how they narrow their
interests or I disagree don't say I want
to investigates how we can use games
with our
yeah yeah games for learning that's
pretty problem
yeah talk about your specific game that
you've been developing or thinking about
or the game that you can playing that
you're really invested in or you know
keep it very specific or give specific
examples to show your interests hang on
sec were you gonna add something easy no
I was just gonna say I I think it it
might be sort of a one-two it's helpful
for me to know what your big interests
are it helps me to know what your
motivations are but one of the things
I'm looking for in master students is
the ability to frame an answerable
question right so giving me a question
that isn't answerable not just been a
masters but on a PhD or in a 20-year
career it's generally just it's sort of
a sign of poor judgment so part of what
I'm looking for is your ability to sort
of be realistic about your time and
everything else that you're being asked
to do in this and to pick off the the
right chunk of work to work on at this
at this moment in your academic career
thank you that's very helpful recent
response that time goes really fast yeah
um one more for the room and then we
have a practical pressure from Shannon
here yes
the documentary films but write an open
doc lab question what if you come from
more theoretical background rather than
a practical maker kind of background
well I mean we balance theory and
practice in all of our in our education
and in our labs and we tailor sort of
the practical side of the education so
but I think theory is good and to have
the overall picture and you know
theoretical understanding of what you're
doing and where it fits in to um you
know sort of the bigger cultural
understanding of documentaries but and
then the P I is a theorist I'm William
Murray Keogh so there's a theory but
that it's very practical work the twenty
hours a week it's very hands-on
practical work yeah yeah I mean it's all
kinds of research skills writing skills
you know no not at all no you just have
to have a good reason why you want to be
in the lab and what you want to learn
from it chin
the question that I know you all want to
know the answer to is does the stipend
to cover a health insurance does the
stipend cover health insurance and the
answer is yes yes good thank you that's
very practically we are almost out of
time so I'm wondering if there's any
last we can end on that practical note
but if anyone has a real zinger to end
with we could also now the pressures on
sure
how does the program change since it
started how do I see it changing in the
future that's a that's a good tough one
I've only been here since 2012 so I
don't think that I have the deep
institutional history it's it's been a
program that has evolved over time and
interesting ways that only since we
merge with the with writing have we sort
of had standalone institutional status
we were more closely aligned with
literature in the past so there been
really interesting changes over time we
are hopeful that we'll make a new hire
in the future so we're trying to you
know keep growing and growing anyone
else have a better question again yes or
ten years oh yeah it has changed and it
really changes based on the faculty that
come in and one of their research areas
and then labs develop out of those
research areas and then also what they
teach and how they change the courses so
yeah its overall comparative Media
Studies and across borders and
institutions and platform some time
periods but then within that it's hugely
dependent on the people that are here
yeah yeah so if we make another hire and
it's someone in you know with a comics
focus that's a whole you know big area
that we haven't had a really hardcore
kind of specialist in or you know we
might go in an area you know so so as
the program grows and we make new hires
and so on makes a difference we can add
something
yeah on a smaller scale I mean each
group of students that comes in
everyone's got yeah these kinds of
different backgrounds and interests and
so each class kind of like almost forms
its own kind of identity and that
ripples through um you know later
generations of students I mean we still
feel a couple years ago definitely last
year and you know I guess we've been
rubbing off some ways on the next period
so yeah it's kind of bacon yeah and it
might if you can all come to the
colloquium at five o'clock with the
Alumni panel that's a range of people
from the class of I think 2000
up to like last year so you'll get a
little more bit of a what 2002 nice
alright so you get a nice the kind of
range a kind of nice picture of alums
past and present and you know give you a
sense of what might have in the future
this this this panel is today at five
o'clock there are maps in the hallway on
that table also fabulous keychains with
little lights on them um SW keychains a
MIDI Aaron
I don't yeah you can open a lock with it
that's gonna be but the it's in is it
building two rooms
two three one thank you billing for room
231 which you can spine on the map where
you can plug it into your phone and MIT
is a bit of a labyrinth right with the
numbers and the hyphens and everything
but if you can't find your way to the
building you probably shouldn't be
coming here anyways there's a building
14 E in a building 14 and the gaps are
endless or endless but I do have to see
many of you there and thank you so much
for coming today we answer a lot of your
questions thanks